Guys, believe it or not,
this was Nate's
idea, not mine.
In today's video,
we are melting over
a hundred lipsticks,
and then we're going to see
if there's anything else we
can do with them after that.
[Music]
We've got over a hundred tubes
of lipstick here,
and they are in a nice
variety of colors,
and I don't honestly know
too much about lipstick.
And we're going
to learn a little bit more
about that today, specifically,
what happens if you heat it up.
Lipstick, I know,
has sort of a really soft,
like a crayon but softer
oil pastel sort of,
a soft wax texture.
And I suspect
that it melts down quite nicely,
and we're going to try
melting it down,
and see what it does.
Here's the basic idea.
We have over a
hundred lipsticks here.
We are going to put
them all in a pot,
put that pot on the stove,
and after that,
we're going to see if there's
anything else we can do.
We do have a bunch
of different colors here,
and we want to see what happens
with all of them combined.
We want to see
if they'll mix well.
Does lipstick boil
if you heat it up too much?
And if it does turn
into a liquid,
can you then cast it
into other shapes?
So every tube of lipstick
that Calli has been opening,
she has all spent applying.
She has probably 25 layers of
lipstick applied at the moment.
So these, these obviously
are not the highest quality
of lipsticks that there are,
but the coverage
happening here...
Yeah, it feels more like
greasepaint than anything else.
Just one.
>> There's no such thing as one.
>> Just one.
Shouldn't he put on just one?
I've put on like 50.
I'm taking one for the team.
There.
There's mine.
[Music]
Most of these lipsticks,
we're going to be
melting in this pot
on the stove all together,
but I did first want to try and
see what happens with just one
of them and a lighter,
see what kind
of melting effect we get.
The first four ingredients
in this is wax.
No, again, we weren't going
for top quality lipstick,
so the pigmentation
is pretty low.
But the wax content
is very high.
So this is just going to run.
[Music]
>> Oh, there's actually more in there.
>> There's quite a bit more down in there.
You just can never get to it.
It's like roasting
a marshmallow,
if a marshmallow was a piece
of pigmented wax you put
on your face for fun.
There's a big bubble in it.
You can see.
That does look pretty cool.
I would say that's not the most
efficient way to melt
these down however,
so I think now we want to take
every one of these lipstick,
the colored part out,
and just put them into this pot.
So I've seen this done before,
and people will put
them in a pot,
and they mix them all together.
No, no. I want to see
if we can get like a cool
rainbow effect or something,
almost like hydro dipping
but sans the hydro part.
Just make it look
a lot cooler as its melting.
See if we can actually
keep that effect.
Once it's melted,
see if we'll keep
that same pattern.
[Music]
All right.
So we've separated
out the colors.
We're going to try to get
that sort of rainbow effect.
So we're going to start
from darker colors,
and work our way over.
[Music]
We've got our lipsticks.
We've got them in our pot.
Let's melt them.
All right.
So we've got
the tripod all set up.
We've got everything
ready to go.
Everything's on the stove.
Let's melts lipstick.
I think we're going to want to go
with the lowest setting to start.
Highest setting.
Oh no.
I'll turn it down low,
just a little.
Like all the way below.
[Music]
Oh-oh.
Whoa.
Oh, that is so much more liquid
than I was expecting.
Super runny.
Oh, but it's
like a bright galaxy.
That's kind of cool.
>> Oh,look at the little spots, yeah.
>> Little bits, yeah.
Shooting up from the bottom.
It also smells a little burned,
but I want to see if I can get
a swirl lipstick out of this.
But I don't want a regular mold.
Look at those
cool swirl patterns.
Oh, that's cool.
So yeah, here's my prediction.
If you see what's coming
off of the spoon after I dip it, it's--
That's clear.
There's not a lot of color.
So what I think is is all
of our pigment has sunk
down to the bottom,
and that's what we're seeing
bubbling up here.
So, let's see what happens
if I try and pour this.
I might just end up
with like a shiny lip gloss.
Yep.
There's all the color.
Look at that.
[Music]
But look at the stripes,
that's so cool.
That's amazing.
[Music]
I have an R2D2 lipgloss.
Before anything else,
we've got these really
good swirls right now.
I'm going to see if we can pick
up some of those swirls
on the surface of
this glass Christmas ornament,
and hopefully,
it won't be so hot
that it breaks the glass.
[Music]
Lipstick ornament.
But yeah, you can see,
that's mostly wax.
There's clear wax.
Like this is covered.
No pigment in it at all.
It's just, they're wax.
Guys, we sell these
now in TheKingofRandom.com.
Go buy yours.
This is going
to be clear, mostly.
This is going to be kind
of a shiny lip gloss.
I'm going to try and mix
the pigment a little bit
more from the bottom,
scrape it up off the bottom,
and give myself
a stormtrooper actual lipstick.
All right, I want
to keep some swirls.
So now that I've got some color
coming up to the surface,
I'm gonna pour this.
[Music]
Oh, I made a mess.
I made a mess everywhere.
This, this silicon
mold has an issue.
It's very thin mold,
but that's okay.
Maybe pour a Darth Vader across
from it to even out the weight.
I know Darth Vader
always wanted to be a lipstick.
But look at the difference
between this color,
and the color of my R2D2.
But at this point,
you can kind of see
that we do have sort
of have one color.
All right, wait,
I'm dipping my entire
glove in this.
I want to see.
Oh, yeah.
Ready?
Oh, that was too hot.
It's too hot.
That's okay.
Best luck.
Oh, a lipstick handprint.
[Music]
This will also be
for sale in our shop.
Give me an ornament.
Hand me.
[Music]
He's separating even more.
Oh, he's a galaxy.
That's so cool.
It's like algae growing
in it or something.
It does.
I'll say this,
even cool, this stuff
does not hold together,
even as strong as
a regular lipstick.
[Music]
Do you think anyone else
in the world has
a stormtrooper lipstick?
Because I do, and I am thrilled.
Look at that.
All right.
I have to try it.
You know I do.
[Music]
Seems to apply all right.
Maybe it's not like super
great coverage but...
All right.
Now, this was pouring
from the very top.
When we melt it
down the lipsticks,
we ended up with that.
The clear coat sort of on top,
just the wax itself,
which is what happened
here with our R2D2.
Some color mixed in,
but definitely not
a nice homogeneous mixture
like these ones.
Here's the interesting thing.
This stuff is just,
the colors not smearing
nearly as easy.
You can actually
see my fingerprints
smearing through this.
So this is just
the very very soft wax.
So this is going to be
like a lip gloss, lip balm?
Let's see.
Oh, but some
pigment settled out.
That's cool.
Didn't see that coming.
No.
Look at that division
on the top, like...
Oh, I loveit.
The different layers.
All right, let's see what this
guy looks like on the inside.
So white on one side.
You can see the color division.
So how the pigment
is actually settling,
which makes me curious
how lipstick is actually formed.
How do they keep it
from doing that?
[Music]
That really divided.
Yeah, but feel
the difference in texture.
This side is very very tough,
and this side is
just soft and squishy.
[Music]
Well, okay, well...
Break.
Whoa!
Some sparkly bits.
I found the glitter,
and that's in the center,
which is interesting.
Look at that.
Yeah, it doesn't really
have it on the edges.
Yeah, it's the center.
I'm going to try
and just snap it,
because I want to know just
how brittle it is,
or if it's been like crumble.
Well, it's actually
pretty tough.
But again, you can see
a color division here.
It's interesting.
You've got the red,
more of the matte pigments
is on the outside,
and then all of our sparkles
are this weird inner layer.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video,
and the box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb
in the middle to subscribe,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.